da sind wir wieder bei hot to handle
neuer tag ich habe rückenschmerzen alles
klar jesus heilt jedoch einfach soll ich
dich massieren
dank der apotheke er hat humor hat die
auch in der letzten folge die kranke
abruf und francesca bekommen
sting ist allerdings dass ich diese
vorher gerade gucke und die wurde vor
fast einem jahr zwei jahren aufgenommen
produzieren von paar monaten licht und
francesca versucht sich jetzt
anscheinend an harry wieder ran zu
machen aber wir sind schon wieder
getrennt wie vor nicht vorgestern
sondern gestern auf das video von harry
dazu reagiert
er ist komisch sich jetzt diese folge
anzuschauen die in der vergangenheit
spielt und wir wissen wie es in der
gegenwart gerade ist egal wir schauen
weiter am morgen nach dem kurs was war
ich morgens echt nett morgen das nicht
ob es da eine verbindung gibt
am morgen nach dem kurs
die haben doch nur geredet da an dem
pool in der letzten folge oder ich will
noch mal ein bisschen zurück wir hatten
ja ein bisschen was übersprungen
da kann ja gar nicht gesehen
mensch also preis hat die lampe chloe
geküsst heißt erhält zwischen den
funkchips ja anders und nachts mit
elektrizität zimmer nie so gut bist du
das auch nicht so gut war
sandras abi vollidiot gestern roadtrip
mit sandra gemacht das war auch schon
wieder wahnsinn
danach waren wir da noch was trinken
ja wenn ihr sowas demnächst komplett
direkt sehen wollt folgt auf instagram
instagram kommt
er hat mich so viel geküsst und ich
dachte da waren keine kunden was die
lambert keine hatte ihn küssen um das
herauszufinden
also sie sagt jetzt gerade der kurs der
hat zwar stattgefunden klar wir auch
gesehen allerdings war da keine funken
das ist irre wenn das eine lampe sagt
weil die lampe oder von über das
funktioniert nicht es gab kein feuerwerk
es war eher ein okay die anderen werden
begeistert sein dass du 3000 dollar
verschuldet und hat für ein
genau das mache ich wenn ich englisch
essen war und dann macht er so ja durch
die haare ganz schlimm herber der war
doch die ganze zeit schon so dass
horrillo aber greift die ganze zeit
schon sofort kommen auf entbot ich bin
30 habe meisten scheiß haley hingegen
sieht das ganz anders aus
ich kann nicht so tun als habe ich
jemanden mag bin ich lieber ehrlich und
werde dafür gehasst
okay ich habe ja versucht aber wenn ihr
jemand den mund aufmacht denke ich nur
okay haley hast grundsätzlich alles und
jeden und ich checke rat dass sich die
heutige folge eigentlich mit dem trecker
aufnehmen wollte die sache da ist
allerdings dass nicht meineid recker
irgendwie verlegt habe oder verschenkt
haben den andern youtuber der damit an
videos aufgenommen hat keine ahnung
wurde auf jeden fall ist aber ich
bestelle mir jetzt 9
und vielleicht noch nicht in der
nächsten tour henry action weil ich weiß
nicht wie lange die brauchen wegen
coroner lieferung und so aber dann in
der übernächsten denke ich mache mir
dann die etracker folge
als das lernen hier nichts außer dass
die leute im haus idioten sind da anders
mit kunden helfen denen er nicht weil
sie so dumm sind und leider ist mir echt
egal
die du wirkst der tabelle schauen wie
man nicht raus als wenn man rausgehen
können nur haley satire meinung also man
kann da auch raus an scheint weil ich
lese auch immer die kommentare die ihm
ihr zahlreich und dass die videos
schreibt da sind auch immer leider
einige spieler dabei und haben einige
schon geschrieben dass auch leute die
staffel verlassen werden
und ich bin gespannt wer das sein wird
und ich denke jetzt gerade wirklich das
es handy sein wie harry hat den mut
gefunden sich gegen alphamännchen kells
aufzulehnen
die quatschen jetzt hat sich direkt nach
meiner sache herangehen
ja aber brot du du hast schon schnitzler
auch behandelt wie sonst was du hast vor
den anderen leuten geprahlt irgendwie
mit ihr dann hast du sie aber angelogen
hat die leute angelogen also ich
verstehe es auch irgendwo klar was
blödes von chefs gesicht direkt
umgeguckt hat aber es ist halt nichts
verboten das so ich weiß das ist eine
situation aber ich will es mit frankie
versuche aktiv ist als erfahrung spiele
nicht unfair das habe ich noch nie
wirklich das stimmt allerdings harry hat
halt regeln gebrochen durch den kuss
einerseits ja andererseits auch dadurch
dass er alle anderen angelogen hat das
ist jetzt zwar keine festgelegte regel
aber für mich auch irgend so ein
bisschen loyalität solidaritäts mäßig
irgendwie unvereinbare allerdings hat
chelsea hat auch nichts verbotenes
gemacht der mit francesca whirlpool
einfach nur schwimmen gelernt da das
soll nicht herablassen klingen jetzt
kommt was herablassendes solcher spiele
nicht in derselben liga
[Musik]
ok
hältst du es richtig auf krawall
gebürstet oder petitionen reife ist ein
wichtiger baustein für lange beziehungen
und eine eigenschaft an der es den jungs
offensichtlich mangelt
im lager um das zu ändern habe ich da
war den herz krieger guru eingeladen er
will einen workshop nur mit den jungs
machen also keine mädels mit drin
er war
j wie kung fu fighting workshops nur für
männer sind wichtig um diesen
schutzschild den während gesellschaft
von frauen um uns haben runterzufahren
okay nur dann quer war herz krieger sie
ja auch aus
und ich möchte versuchen ein teil eures
herzens zu erwecken wir vielleicht bis
jetzt im tiefschlaf dies glaube
gerade bei den beiden wird sehr spannend
steht so ein großer starker typ vor uns
in langen hosen
es ist so heiß
[Musik]
das nennt man dann danke für dieses
mentale bild harry ja also die
emotionale reife haben etwas gemeinsam
ist dass weder als männer ist das
einzige wasser oder wir alle kommen aus
der erde
ich komme aus meiner mutter ja denke ich
mir auch gerade und die erde heute
nutzen um uns alle hier zu einer großen
einheit zu verbinden
das ist eine mission da gerade also
greift zu und nehmt euch einen batzen
erde aus dieser schiffsausflug wie
sollen sie denn da ist ja nicht wirklich
erde
ich habe
wohin folgen gesagt ich sehe mich da ich
hätte auch über bock drauf so eine
experimente und so was alles ist ein
bisschen so wie diese ganzen rtl shows
aber halten hochqualitativ auf netflix
und cool gemacht mit dem richtigen
hintergedanken aber spätestens da will
ich sagen wo ich fasse jetzt nicht in
diesem scheiss erde einmal rein jetzt
schmiert damit den man für euch ein als
herz krieger
das ist doch
hat macht er erfinden
was soll der scheiß leider ja
scheiß dich mal voll ist kann der erde
drin sondern ich sage dir was ist das
hey wir machen die ein emotionaler reife
workshops anstatt dass wir uns irgendwie
war sachen unterhalten thesen aufstellen
und uns genau überlegen hey was geht in
den herzen welcher person ab nee wir
nehmen uns erde und spielen sie
demgegenüber auf die brust
emotionale reife alles einfach nur
ekelhaft
ja das stimmt kelter gebe ich dir da zu
ernst genommen
ins gesicht doch jesus auch mit der mit
der uhr hier also dass
tanz workshop es braucht viel mut und
stärke um sich gegen
[Musik]
was falsch bei dir hier sind verbunden
ihr sollt die waren auch ohne die erde
im gesehen verbunden
sarah koba also es wurde ja völlig
übertrieben wenn paar sekunden später
[Applaus]
was was ist dass viele folge auf zur
nächsten aufgabe hertha es gibt noch
eine aufgabe nimmt dieses weiße blatt
papier das mit worten die für das stehen
was euch zurückhält
das kenne ich von den workshops habe ich
auch schon mal gemacht das ist richtig
gut wirklich wenn es euch irgendwie
scheiße geht also jetzt mal wirklich
kurz rialto wenns euch irgendwie scheiße
geht nehmt euch einfach ein blatt papier
oder keine ahnung was einen und tietze
neppert weiß ich und schreiben einfach
die sachen auf weswegen ihn als scheiße
geht und dann denken einfach warum ist
dem so wie kann ich das verändern wie
kann ich diese einzelnen sachen
eliminieren
denkt nicht allzu viel nach einfach
direkt auf schreiben malen da sogar
richtig
das
finde ich sehr gut fiel sehr nice diesen
workshop heute feiert die folge bisher
sie hat im gegenteil lustiger aspekte
drehen wir wollten diese steine stammen
allerdings auch so was wieder also die
serie ist mittlerweile richtig ja du
bist aber ganz kurz nämlich überspringen
ja manchmal ein paar passagen wenn es
komplett sehen wollt cook bei netflix
vorbei ist keine bezahlte werbung
hier steht jetzt aber werbevideo wall
transparenz und so ja wo ich jetzt aber
gerade schon werbung mache weil liebe
freunde können auch mal luca - stockum
de vorbeischauen das beste auf der welt
zeigt euch nun gegenseitig eurer poster
untereinander euch zu sehen wir einmal
nachlässt altes los um nach vorn blicken
zu können mega geil jetzt sogar
übersetzt vergangenheit leid zukunft
unsicher krass
die folge geht ans herz
die beiden haben da ihre ganzen sachen
aufgeschrieben
ich sehe höre jetzt mit anderen augen
obwohl es bis zu einem kleinen bruder
gänsehaut kranke folge wirklich extrem
geile folge zeigt eure massig und nehmt
es am alter ich sitze hier mit gänsehaut
es ist eine wundervolle folgen
wundervolles entnehmen die sich in die
arme ich muss die folge da heute
behinderte sind wunderschön das ende
meiner lieben freundinnen ding sagt ja
ein bisschen streit wegen horrender die
beiden hat beschreibt wegen von chats
gabe jetzt sind alle happy sind wenn ihr
euch die heutige bisoli gefallen habe
ihm freude zeigt wie gern mit einer
bewertung schaffen wir sind 60.000
leicht und jetzt befinden uns auch schon
im auto meiner lieben freunde wenn ihr
noch kein abonnent von einem kanal sei
dann klingt mal ganz schnell auf dieses
mal die da ich sehen wir dass ganz viele
meine videos schauen ohne dass die
abonnent von einem kanal sind also go
ahead click darauf verpasst keine videos
mehr ist kostenlos und hier ist noch mal
eine reaktion auf harrys break up video
exploration verlinkt also ich möchte das
auch normal wenn ihr wollt